الله سبحانه وتعالى يقول اذا اردت ان تعرف
اني انا الخالق انظر الى الابل كيف خلقت
هي بهيمه ولكنها هي من الانعام ربي حتى ما
اطلق عليها كلمه بهيمه في القران الكريم
يعني دينيا لها مكانه عندنا اجتماعيا لها
مكانه ثقافيا لها مكانه فكيف نبالغ هذه ما
مبالغه بالعكس نحن مقصرون في حق
[موسيقى]
الابل عبد الله بن محمد بن غازي بن عوده
العتيبي صار ل مجال ابل حوالي 23 24 سنه
24 عام من الامتلاك يعني بداياتي هي فقط
الترفيه كان عندي مزرعه يعني في جده وحطيت
فيها ابل ل حليبها لان حليبها هو غذاء
ودواء فكنت انا يعني اخذ هذه الابل مجرد
النظر اليها والرفاهيه واعلم عيالي يعني
ان هي شعارنا وهي رمز ثقافتنا وتقاليدنا
يعني كمجتمع سعودي
وايضا بداوتنا المنافسات كلها من يوم بديت
باسم ابني محمد اول شيء اعزز فيه هذا
اربطه بحياه البداوه هنا زي ما قلتلك ها
ثقافتنا البدويه نحيها في اطفالنا نفتخر
فيها يعني كشعار هذه غير كذا ان امه يعني
امه الله يطول في
عمرها سموني سفير قالت انا السفيره تقول
باسم ابني انت تشارك باسمك والله يعني لا
تنوم نفسك باسم ابني باسم ابني توكلنا على
الله وهي تستاهل ولدها
[ضحك]
يستاهل
هي غير محدده الان اسعارها الابل ولا
تعتبر اصول وغير مربوطه بوزاره العدل ولا
نظام ابشر ولا حاجه ولا ولا هي مربوطه ب
الزكاء والدخل ولا شي فبتالي اسعارها هي
حره انت حر انا مثلا ابغى بكره اكلم احد
اقول جيبها لي باي سعر انا احدده هو المان
اللي بيشتري والي يحدد والبائع واحيانا
البايع يرضخ للسوق لان احيانا ما ف يعني
ما في تداول ما في كذا هي تحدد اسعارها
اللي يقول بنتج بشتري هذه البكره خليها
تكبر عندي وانتج منها السعر اللي يدفعه
غير السعر هذا اللي يبغاها للمنافسه غير
لان المنافسه انت هي يعني ترتبط بالشخص
ومجتمعه قبيلته تقاليده سمعته سمعه قبيلته
هذا فبالتالي يبذل الغالي والنفيس لحصول
عليها ويزيد
عليها هو اهل الابل اهل الابل اللي يعني
المعروفين و ما يعرفوا حتى ايش معناها
كلمه غسيل الاموال صراحه وان جلست مع
بعضهم الكبار السن يفكر غسيل الاوال
تغسلها بالمويه تغسلها وتطلع فلوس هذا
القطاع هو كامل لابد يتحكم صناعته تتحكم
يضع لها مواصفات ومعايير ومقاييس حتى
نستطيع نصدر هذا المنتج الى العالم يعترف
به ايضا البيع والشراء لا بد يكون
الكتروني حتى نتلا هذا الشيء هي هذه
الثغرات اللي جعلت ان في ناس تستقل من
ضعفاء
يعني يستغل هذا الوضع وعدم يعني الحوكمه
الدقيقه واجراءات الماليه الدقيقه يعني
عدم تنفيذها في قطاع الابل ويستغلها
لصالحه هم معظمهم ما هم يعني هم معظمهم من
يعني جنسيات اخرى ما هي ما هم سعوديين
يعني قطاع الابل مهيمن على بيعه وشراءه
الان في وقتنا الحاضر
يعني الجاليه السودانيه باعتبارهم بدو
واهل الابل وهكذا وجدوا هذا القطاع فيه ث
فان هي يعني ي استغلوه الاموال اللي
يحصلون عليها ما يستفيد منها احنا لا
ضرائب ولا تدخل حتى النظام المالي حقنا
يتحول مباشره الى الخارج وبدعم منه يعني
بالتستر من كفيله ومن صاحبه السعوديين لهم
دور في هذا الشيء وهذا شيء
منسف هو فيها يعني ناس تحفز مثل القصص
الشعبيه هذه لما الواحد يجي يقص قص قص
قبيلتين تناحر وعشان نياج ياخذون نياق
وهذا ويجي يلقيها الان بطريقه ثانيه ويجي
شاعر يعزز له ويسوي قصيده وتروح يجي واحد
يسوي شيله ويعزز لله ويسويها شيله وقناه
تيوب تاخذها هذا غير صحيح هذا هو اللي خطا
يعني في عالم الابل نبتعد عن هذه لان هذه
تثير النزاع القبلي والتناحر اثناء
المنافسات والمهرجانات
الشريفه تنميه طريه الابل لا يوجد لها
علاج نحن نستخدم علاج الابقار والمواشي
الاخرى في الابل او الطب الشعبي يعني كوي
الكي و خلطات اعشاب وخلطات من خضروات وكذا
الحليب ما تعرف هل هذا هو صالح للشرب ام
لا بسبب عدم وجود مواصفات ومعاير تحدد
فيها السكر الدهون اللكتوز
الاغبر الكتله لابد يكون في تحليل جينوم
في الابل تحليل الكائ تحليل الديني وهذه
تحفظ ونعرف سلات الاب في العالم كله لان
احنا الملكه العربيه السعوديه المركز
العالمي اللوجستي اللي يدير هذا الكائن
الان يدير جميع شؤون
الابل لا ما غير حق غير صحيح الاب الابل
اكثر كائن لطيف ووديع وله حقود ولا شي
ولكنه يلعب يجي يلعب معك
ويكسرك ضربه منه وهو قصده يعني مداعبه
الان كل 100 ناقه دائما عندنا يحطوا معه
فحل واحد الفحل هذا يرعاها ويلف عليه اذا
شاف انيا طلعت منها اثناء يعني يعني الرعي
يروح يردها ويضربها واذا شف فحل جاي يروح
يتقاتل معه هذه فطره الله سبحانه وتعالى
خلقها انه فحل ويحافظ على مجموعتها اما
حقد انها تحقد وانها بعدين ينتقم هذه
اشاعات اساس نكره الابل هذا غير صحيح
اتحداها تثبت هذه قصص شعبيه قصص شعبيه غير
يعني
صحيحه انا لما جيت انا انظر ل اول شركه
ابل في السعوديه والوحيده الى الان وكان
فيها من واحد منكل الابل جا وقال انا ادفع
كذا وهي لي وه ليست لفلان انا قلت هذه
فلان انتب تشتريها لفلان اللي هو ينافسني
فقال لا وثقت وبعته بقيمه سويت ديسكاونت
فانا جيت وهم قالوا الفجر نحمل ورحت على
اساس يعني اودعها واقول لها باي باي
وشالوا كل شي خلوا
الركبي انا وعيت قلت الركبي طيب ايش نسوي
فيه يبقى هو الركبي اللي يركب الراعي قت
اي تسوي خذوه يا شباب هذا قالوا لا هذا مو
ضمن البيعه طلعوا في قال لا خليه لك هذا
مابغاه فحسيت ان في اضطهاد الركبي حقي
زعلت قلت والله ما عاد ابيعك اقعد الى
الان هو موجود
بالنسبه للابل المزايين هذه غير ما تقدر
تستغلها صناع التحويليه كلحوم وكجو تاخذ
جلدها وابرها او حليبها بالعكس هذه هي فقط
مسابقات الجمال ودخلت خسرت ملايين وكسبت
ملايين اكثر يعني انا حققت اللي ابيه
وحققت فوز وحققت ارقام قياسيه فيها وبعدين
بعت
بمكسب بعتها بمكسب وطلعت يعني الحمد لله
يعني كسبان طلعت اللي خسرته زياده يعني
انا شريت ب 60 مليون وشريت بعدها بحوالي
18 مليون لكن لما جيت وبعتها هي
دخلت يعني قيمه ماليه غير القيمه المعنويه
اللي انا كنت ابحث عنها اللي هي يعني
الفوز والكاسات يكون لك اسم في عالم الابل
وفي منافسات مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز طيب
الله تراى على هذا مهرجان عالمي لما تكون
ف وتحقق فوز كبيره هذه يعني ارث يبقى لك
ابنائك وابناء
ابنائك هي هي بهيمه ولكنها هي من الانعام
ربي حتى ما اطلق عليها كلمه بهيمه في
القران الكريم غير لما جمعوها في الزكاه
بهام والانعام فقط وانما هو قال ناقه الله
وسقياها الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم اوصى
عليها الرفق بها والعنايه بها وهي من
الكائنات يعني الجنه ان شاء الله وهذا
موجود في الحديث وهي في
يعني دينيا لها مكانه عندنا اجتماعيا لها
مكانه ثقافيا لها مكانه فكيف نبالغ هذه ما
مبالغه بالعكس نحن مقصرون في حق الابل
وبسبب زي ما
قلتلك الاعلام الاعلام المرئي وسوء تعامله
مع الابل في الغرب مع مرور السنين ما يجيب
انه صديق للانسان انه صحراوي وانه يعني
حتى يطلعوا اشعات ان الابل تحقد وانها
تقتل وتسوي وتفعل انا يقول حيوان قلت لا
تقول حيوانات على الابل هذ اول اي اول
واحد انا اتكلم في هذا الشيء قال واحد هذه
مسابقه حيوانات مسابقه بهائم قلت له يا
اخي ماي مسابقه بهايم وين نافس ولا تقول
على ابل بهايم هذه كائنات يعني ربي يفتخر
في خلقها وهذه
يعني ايه للانبياء يعني ايه للانبياء
ناقه قوم هود صالح خرجها من الصخره عشراء
معها ابنها عش وتكفي يوم حليب المدينه
كلها يعني المملكه يعني هذا هذه المدينه
الحضاره كانت واحده ناق تكفيها ويوم سقيا
لها ويوم سقي لهم هي ايه من ايات الله
يعتبر يعتبر هو فيه فيه تهديد لبقاء
القبيله وايضا انتهاك لكرامه كرامه
القبيله الى الان هذا الشيء موجود اقول لو
معك ناقه بدل سياره وصلت اسرع ها قلت له
نشق والله قلتها له لو معانا الحين جايين
على رحول نشق
ونمشي كيف الشخصيه بس ممتازه ذمتك انت
تبغاني مبهل عشان تقول هذ العينه هذ لا
والله انهم ممتازين الله
يحييك بالله تسجلون تطلعوني
كذا